what do you do about the about the
negative guy that's trying to bring you
down and sure you can you can confront
them right and you can by doing that
join in their in their little game and
in doing that you give them the
satisfaction they now know that they got
it to your head and and then you're
turning your workplace until you know
your basic grade school gossip all so we
don't like that but now there are times
unfortunately that you you have to
address things and when you do it you do
it professionally and you do it your
goal is to disarm them because remember
that this negative person inside they
probably want the confrontation that's
what they want but the preferred
methodology for this situation for me is
quite simple
and that is ignore and outperform them
while you're over there watching me and
talking about me I'm working I'm working
hard I'm taking things to the next level
and keep gossiping and I'll keep working
you keep talking smack and I'll keep
working you keep focusing on everything
and everyone else and I'll keep working
and when you finally look around that
where you are and where I'm at you
realize that you have nothing left to
talk smack about if you will lose and I
will win